Have you...
ever been in love?
Yep. Nancy Wheeler.
First semester, senior year.
[imitates gunshot, chuckles]
Oh, my God.
She's such a priss.
[Steve] Hm.
Turns out, not really.
[scoffs]
Are you still in love with Nancy?
-No.
-Why not?
I think it's because I found someone
who's a little bit better for me.
[chuckles] It's crazy.
Ever since Dustin got home,
he's been saying,
"You know, you gotta find your Suzie.
You gotta find your Suzie."
Wait, who's Suzie?
It's some girl from camp,
I guess his girlfriend.
To be honest with you,
I'm not 100% sure she's even real.
But that's not--
that's not really the point.
That doesn't matter. The point is,
this girl, you know, the one that I like,
it's somebody that I...
didn't even talk to in school.
And I don't even know why.
Maybe 'cause Tommy H.
would've made fun of me or...
I wouldn't be...
prom king.
It's stupid. I mean, Dustin's right,
it's all just a bunch of bullshit anyways.
Because, when I think about it,
I should've been hanging out
with this girl the whole time.
First of all, she's hilarious.
She's so funny.
I feel like, this summer,
I have laughed harder
than I have laughed...
in a really long time.
And she's smart.
Way smarter than me.
You know, she can crack, like,
top secret Russian codes and...
You know? She's honestly unlike anyone
I've ever even met before.
Robin?
[tapping on stall]
Robin, did you just OD in there?
No. [sighs]
I...
am still alive.
[deep sigh]
[Robin] The floor's disgusting.
Yeah, well, I already got a bunch of blood
and puke on my shirt, so...
What do you think?
About?
This girl.
She sounds awesome.
She is awesome. And what about the guy?
I think he's on drugs,
and he's not thinking straight.
Really? 'Cause I think he's thinking
a lot more clearly than usual.
He's not.
Look...
he doesn't even know this girl.
And if he did know her,
like-- like really know her,
I don't think he'd even want to be
her friend.
No, that's not true. No way is that true.
Listen to me, Steve.
It's shocked me to my core,
but I like you.
I really like you.
But I'm not like your other friends.
And I'm not like Nancy Wheeler.
Robin, that's exactly why I like you.
[Robin scoffs]
Do you remember what I said
about Click's class?
About me being jealous and, like,
obsessed?
Yeah.
It isn't because I had a crush on you.
It's because...
she wouldn't stop staring at you.
Mrs. Click?
[chuckles]
Tammy Thompson.
I wanted her to look at me.
But... she couldn't
pull her eyes away from you
and your stupid hair.
And I didn't understand,
because you would get
bagel crumbs all over the floor.
And you asked dumb questions.
And you were a douchebag.
And-- And you didn't even like her and...
I would go home...
and just scream into my pillow.
But Tammy Thompson's a girl.
[softly] Steve.
Yeah?
Oh.
Holy shit.
Yeah.
Steve...
did you OD over there?
No, I just, uh...
just thinking.
Okay.
I mean, yeah.
Tammy Thompson, you know,
she's cute and all, but...
I mean,
she's a total dud.
She is not.
Yes, she is.
She wants to be, like, a singer.
She wants to move to, like,
Nashville and shit.
-She has dreams.
-She can't even hold a tune.
She's practically tone-deaf.
Have you heard her?
-[Robin chuckles]
-All the time.
[singing atonally]
♪ You see me now tonight ♪
-Shut up.
-♪ You see me... ♪
-She does not sound like that.
-She sounds exactly--
-That's a great impersonation of her.
-She does not.
You sound like a Muppet.
She sounds like a Muppet.
She sounds like a Muppet giving birth.
[both laughing]
[sings like Kermit]
♪ And if you could hold me tight ♪
[both sing atonally]
♪ We'll be holding on forever ♪
-Exactly.
-[laughs] I know!
Okay.
What the hell?
[both laugh]